.
TO VITED STAS THE
WORLD.HN KING INWASHIN.THANK YOR
THE COVIDITIV T WING SO EAMP MPP
PRESIDENTIALAN,
HICKS,CONW,CHRIS RI S THAT
POUSE T  LD.RDLESS OF PIVSES,
THE PREST TO
TH GET TO THEWHITE HOE.HE WILL
YT-
ED TOBREATHE,AS TROVED F
ES. SECT EIMS ESTERDAY TO WAVEC
INVOLVED IN THEESIDENT'S TRUT T
PRESIDENT'S DOC
THEPRRIRAYMPTOMS.
IN OTHER OON. GUIDELINES ARE
WHORSO FROM THE TIME TY GET SYYH
REDONE, THOSE ENERALOTOTPEOPLE.
>> THE WTE HOUSEY AS WED,Y, N TT
POSITIVE COVID-19.
GET TOCOLLE WE.UNNGIND YOUUS
>> ReporYEE'RESEEING HOWY TESTE
CONTINUING TOROW.JOHN, WHILE WE
YL AND THAT
SHE HAS AY FROMCORONAVIRUS, THI
TO  WASTHURSDAY HOPE HICKS TES
POSITIVE AHE WAS WHO CONSIDEDIR
CONTACH
HOWEVER,ID QUARANTINE H INTO SU
TESTS T EVERY DAYND
CONTIN T TO WORK
DID ON FRIDAY WHENWITH REPORTER
MINUTES, BUT
MASK OFF AS
APPROAG
IT SHOWS THIS OFNSE
HOUSE WHERE SHE HA A YOU'VE SER.
ACTUALLY TWO PEOPLE. ALSO OBVIO
OLDERE
IN DIRECT O
IN QUARA SHE C NOT
TO DO THAT AS HAVE SEVERAS  JUS
D, AND INSTERENE TESTSPOSITIVE.
CONTINUOOR BEENANY REER.
NO QUAIN
RK NEXT T
WEEKS.
IS RAISESNS OR PEO THAT ONEGAES.
IEF OF INE COMES TO .
HIS S H IVE ONCE AGAIN
HE IS SOMEOHAEN AT WALTER REED
YESTERDAY, THERE DID HISTY ADVI
SECRETARYURE FROM THEMP RECEIVIG
BRIEFING,  SAYS IN T
THAT MARK MEADOWS IRO.E WAS NOTS
S WASN'
UEIO RPOHISD HOW  BESTN
THEY TAK CASES OFUA
THEY WERE TOLD ADVISED
TO DEGUIDELIN,
INSTEAD GS
IMROM CORONAVIRUS.ING WITH KIGA
WHENHEED
ASKTHURSDAY.BU SHE WAS PULLED
OFF THE TRIP TO NTDAING SOMETHI
HICKSTEINS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE. C
E, DANSH
ASSISTANTEC OF HEAHWITH LL YERT
AND THEF SLED
AND WHAT SD WE DOTHE PRESIDENH
HOUSE, WHAT MUST BE DONET
JO TESERE WHITE AOF THE OFWH TH
OVER MANY MONTHS. GNES CLEAR.
IF ISDIAGNOSEHE
NEED T I GETHEAT NEED ANDE WHOX.
TH IN T M
CA,
THERE'S SO MAN QNS ABO OF HIS
SEVEREIS
ONE   IS
RECEIV THON
RESERV OE WH RAISESONUT
HIS TAS PNEUM
GGING TESTS
GH HIM BACKO THE WHITE H V ME A
FRAGILENDO BE
PROTD. NEEDS TYVES THEESTOT
WE'LL SEE, HEARSTO TI O OF THE .
THAT'S BUILTKSO SPITAL I THITBE
ITOOKEA9
YSE AN ELE LAST NIGHT,E
AGENTS A DEEP RISN S THET.
VY
I
I LEARNED IT BYEALLY GOING
SCHOOL.
THIS IECHOOL.
THIS ISN'T T
BOOK SL. GET IT AND
IT.
OES
UNRSSVICE AGES  RISKAVG FIVE
DAYS WOULD TELL Y
ATEAAY AT JUSTTL WHITE  THEOE A
FUNDIS HOPE HICKS
AND HE WA  EXPOSED.
KAYLEIGH McENANY THEFT AROUND H
SCOLHE H A ENTIRE C S
WHY D H
THBUT N OUABSO
HE ISOLICOW FD W SHOWEMPATHY,
FPRESIDENT.
BUT YOU'REIG. THE THE HAS TAKENA
IDEA TO GO IIS WHICHEALED W OTH
AT R. TO TT HI T TRAINOTA